don't leave
goodbye
she'll be just fine without me
i'm not good i've been throwing myself
into work again
going out with you at least you guys got
to say goodbye
as far as i'm concerned lucifer can well
he can go to hell we
don't need him
[Music]
hello bad guys
[Applause]
you're here yes i got a bit bored so i
thought it popped back
up lucifer is
acting different down there time is
different
i was in hell for thousands of years a
few things might have changed
lucifer 2.0 you're back
great
how could you go home without me i'm not
lucifer
lucifer told me he had a twin brother
nice to meet you i'm michael
i am not gonna break lucifer's life i'm
gonna take it
he is stronger than you think
what do you truly desire
welcome home how do you like the mess i
[Music]
made
for now i'm gonna stick to police work
and avoid anything god related
hilarious
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my lucifer season 5
trailer video
fresh off of crisis on infinite earth so
i will address some of the crossover
easter eggs justice league dark in the
constantine stuff they've been talking
about recently if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos
all the episodes or at least the first
half of the season is going to be
dropping in
august they're going to drop the second
half of the season probably sometime
early next year but there are 16
episodes during season 5.
as you can see the big twist of season 5
is that they're doing the archangel
michael
finally he's the twin brother of lucifer
within the world of the show
they haven't revealed too much about the
plot other than he's trying to take
lucifer's life on earth for himself and
everything that he has
like he's going after chloe he's going
after his friends literally trying to
take his life
all while lucifer is still stuck being
the king of hell again
until eventually towards the end of the
trailer you see that he makes it back to
earth and the rest of the season winds
up being lucifer versus michael
angel war the main differences between
the two of them as you could probably
tell during the trailer footage
is that lucifer has a british accent and
white wings
michael has an american accent in black
wings so that's how you're meant to tell
them apart when they're fighting each
other on screen
but as you could probably guess is the
way these stories tend to go when they
pick up in the season and he just
shows up again and surprises everyone
like lucifer what are you doing back
here
he's pretending to be lucifer imitating
his british accent so i think for the
first part of the season most of the
audience will know what's going on but
the other characters won't figure out
that it's not lucifer till a little bit
later
for those of you wondering what's going
on with the show in general because
there was talk about being cancelled
renewal netflix has renewed the show for
season six so tom ellis the main
characters are coming back
that will be the final season though
they haven't revealed how many episodes
it'll be
but i'm assuming they're going to drop
the episodes before the end of 2021
but no word on who the villain of that
season would be whether they're gonna do
a bigger version of the god character or
which new characters they'd introduce
or potential crossovers all of the dc
shows for that matter that lucifer
crossed over with during crisis on
infinite earth won't even be coming back
till 2021 just because the virus shut
down production for so long
but the whole thing with lucifer the
past couple of seasons in heading into
the final seasons his big internal
conflict
was his identity through the way his
powers his wings his devil face worked
so at the end of season four he goes
back to hell because he's no longer
running away from his responsibilities
he's
accepted it he's a little more confident
in his identity but he feels like he
can't be on earth with chloe anymore
because he's supposed to be the king of
hell i have to go back
so for how long like a couple
couple weeks or a month or
you were right about the prophecy we did
get it wrong it is about hell
coming to earth and we may have stopped
it now but for how long
i need to keep them contained they must
have a king
it's a lot like thor's story in the mcu
thor is supposed to become king of
asgard but he wants to have fun with all
of his friends the avengers all the time
in terms of the dynamic between lucifer
and chloe and how her powers work
they've kind of answered that the past
couple of seasons like why is lucifer
mortal when he's in proximity to her but
it doesn't work on other immortal beings
well the show has suggested that it's
actually because god
wanted to do lucifer a solid when he
became the king of hell eventually
wanted to do him a solid he had a
menadil bless a baby
in the past that wound up being chloe so
she has this very
cosmically miraculous birth her passive
ability
makes immortal beings like lucifer
mortal again and the theory here is it's
when they fall in love with her so that
lucifer would eventually be able to have
a version of a happy ending and live out
a normal life with her his
endgame could be living a normal life
bearing new children
having a normal life on earth if that's
what he wanted
so they'll probably just finally answer
that once and for all during season six
the show is never
concrete answered that explicitly but
they've kind of implied that that's the
case
there was a time on the show when he was
around her and he was still
immortal so the theory there is that was
just before he fell in love with her so
the minute he started to fall in love
with her that's when he started to
become mortal when he was around her
you probably spotted a couple visual
easter eggs in some of the episodes
during that footage too there's 2001
space odyssey here just a cool visual
reference
this whole scene of the kid riding the
tricycle through the hotel looks like
it's right out of the shining
but the whole deal with the crisis on
infinite earth's crossover is that now
the lucifer tv show is confirmed to be
part of the arrow
multiverse however you want to think
about it they got kind of weird with the
way they're explaining that after the
big rebirth event at the end of crisis
before they rebooted everything it was
on earth 666.
they did a big crossover scene with
constantine because in the comics
lucifer knows constantine the lucifer
comic book is kind of like a spin-off of
the hellblazer comic book
oh you're gonna love her she's pretty
much up for everything
always a pleasure to see you lucy
it's time excuse me ladies
seems like you're not the only ones who
want a piece of me i'll see you later
gianni i'd like to say it's a pleasure
to see you
on my earth outside my club it's not
look i don't know if you have an oliver
queen on your world but i was as a
shuffled off this mortal coil a soul
retrieval blah blah blah the worlds are
ending it's all very biblical john
okay okay i'm only doing this because i
owe you for maize yeah you do
you remind me my brother by the way tall
dark annoyed by me
you're gonna help us on that oh flat
the devil always sees through on a deal
so during that scene they just talk
about their implied history it sounds
like they've had many adventures
together in the multiverse
that was why they did that lucifer's
always been a dc character at dc comics
the reason why they couldn't do big
crossovers before
was mostly just because it was fox that
was doing the show and it was owned by
another network so there was a lot of
politics and red tape behind that
now that the show's been at netflix in
season four that's not as big a deal
netflix is pretty cool about doing stuff
like that
they really only needed tom ellis for
this scene so it was just really quick
and easy for them to do
and tom ellis was just a total dude and
happy to show up and help out
jj abrams is also getting ready to do
the big budget
hbo justice league dark series so
obviously we're doing a lot more
supernatural characters
matt ryan constantine from the
arrowverse has said that he wants to
play the constantine of that justice
league dark series but they haven't
confirmed their cast yet they will be
filming that show next year though
the whole idea with a lot of the dc hbo
shows that's different from the cw dc tv
shows
is that they're going to be a little
more closely connected to the dc movies
but i think they're kind of playing that
by ear
because we have the green lantern hbo
series that's coming up that might be
connected to the green lantern core
movie that they're still working on they
just announced that big batman hbo tv
series based on robert pattinson's
batman that's going to start filming
next year too
it's based around the gotham city police
department they've already confirmed
that that will be connected to the new
robert pattinson batman movies
marvel's kind of doing the same thing
with its disney plus series like you
have one division falcon and winter
soldier with the movie actors
some of the new characters that they
introduced during those series will show
up in future marvel movies so i'm
assuming dc is just planning on doing
the same thing with their really big
budget
hbo series so it should all be really
cool there's a lot of really cool
programming coming next year
but everyone let me know in the comments
if you spotted any big easter eggs in
the trailer that i didn't mention during
the video
it's a pretty straightforward cell
lucifer vs michael
angel war for the rest of the season
everyone click here to learn about the
michael keaton batman deleted scene from
crisis on
infinite earth's and click here to learn
about that new batman hbo
tv series thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]